[Music]
hydrogenation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John Humphrey we
are covering the mandalorian here on
YouTube you should go check out our
reactions to a full international
another patreon page it's about time we
learned the history of the Mandalore's
we have a top awards here video request
today from man named TJ trakis the man
with the hottest wall wife to hot he
doesn't deserve her you don't deserve
her you should know this you're out
worthy this comes from the channel meta
nerds lore Mandalorian documentary
24,000 years of honor this is a long one
people link to the original video in the
description box it's time to learn and
then we'll talk about it see how this
ties in here is why you cannot
exterminate us over 18 we're not huddled
in one place we span the galaxy we need
no lords or leaders so you cannot
destroy our command we can live without
technology so we can fight with our bare
hands
we have no species or bloodline so we
can rebuild our ranks with others who
want to join us or more than just the
people or an army our ad or a culture or
an idea and you can't kill ideas but we
can certainly kill you
what's that military and copyright
essentially a documentary on the
Mandalorians or as they're called in
their own language
the mandawa day meaning the children of
Mandalore like that quote mentions the
Mandalorians aren't a species but a
culture we'll get into their origins
their history I don't like the Greg watt
is very similar breed notable Mendo a
day across history and their constant
and important role as a third party
wildcard in galactic Affairs our story
starts around 24,000 years before the
Battle of Yavin when the tongue species
were entrenched in a war of elimination
against it Zell the Zell are the human
natives to Khorasan they've been
fighting the tongue for centuries when a
volcano erupted and leveled the humans
capital the tongue saw a chance at
victory launching intense raids over the
next two years as Coruscant was plunged
into total darkness the atmosphere is
full of volcanic ash
the tongs terrifying raids would be
immortalized in a poem that is still
known throughout the galaxy called the
way that better day the Warriors of
Shadow the tongues whole culture
revolved around war with the society
being loosely assembled warrior clans
that all followed their chieftains they
would give their children names like
Atkin coughed and tore meaning
persistent strength and justice while
their gods reflected this warlike nature
as well kadha raingear was a god who
used conflicts to improve the war looks
like the predator of the fittest both in
your own behaviors your family but also
in the world around you
the idea that competition was a way to
accelerate natural selection
war is applied on a massive scale yes
yes thank you
I agree clearly born in the wrong place
conquering in this culture has the
equivalents of happiness or well-being
in most earth cultures philosophically
and religiously are usually considered
to be goods in themselves yeah sure
whatever why someone would prefer to be
happy likewise the Tom would have not
understood why they had to explain why
combat was preferable to peace exactly
further to this point the opposing God
into reality is not a devil that
corrupts there wants to spread misery
the tongue god that needs to be resisted
was a rasam this is a really old
Mandalore if the SIF mantra reads peace
is a lie
you could think of these early
Mandalorians as believing that peace is
a sin
this is enshrined in a body of facts
called the canons of honor which had
within it the rest'll nor a meaning the
six actions as well as commentaries from
wise tonk chieftains a notable quote
reads I adhere to the race denarii the
core of what it means to be Mandalorian
the sacred law giving us direction and
purpose education and armor self-defense
our tribe our language our leader all
help us survive we must educate our
children as Mandalorians obey the
commands of Mandalore speak mandola and
defend our clans in Catholic school the
Mandalorian armor wasn't
rind is something to keep holy and
forever tied to being one of the men
today symbolizing the keeping of these
virtues the tonal armor had this metal
helmet that was form-fitting upon the
triangular heads and you can see how
this early armor that accommodated the
room for the eyes and their pointed jaws
remained and look in the helmets even as
it changed over tens of thousands of
years but despite this warring culture
the original human core Asante simply
outnumbered the shadow warriors they
were eventually able to push the tongue
off their homeworld at this point there
is a split where a peace-loving sect of
priestly female tong fled a chorus on
for the Unknown Regions but the majority
of them went to that's where Greg
travels to rim this was to get rejected
by every woman on that land but also
because they would stay here or
wallowing in obscurity and weakness for
about 17,000 years the years 7,000 BBY
would see the rise of taste Sola
Mandalore or Mandalore the first the
first to use the title sole ruler
translated to Mandalore he would become
informed the Mandalorian crusader of
course that spread out conquering world
after world in the outer rim hell yeah
and he came across a planet in Sector oh
seven that had plenty of fresh water and
farmable land but also an incredibly
unique material called vesco called
water love iron or cancer could
withstand multiple blows from
lightsabers and yet was malleable enough
to be crafted into armor it seemed the
war god had blessed their return to
conquering with this perfect world to
become the capital of the Mandalore
Empire and it was thus named Mandalore
the only problem was the native
population the mythos ores are enormous
I'll kick them out it's our land now
people American Way manifest destiny by
the Mandalorians as proof that this
world was reserved for the ultimate
warrior it's just the testing this
crusaders accoutrement for all to see
how large are we've seen that yeah
the creatures goal would become
synonymous with the strength that was
adorable symbol it would be to Sarah
more well-known respected jewels across
the gala
see for thousands of years to come over
the next three thousand years they
consolidated their new territory in the
outer-rim spreading out from Mandalore
to capture nearby Ordo Gargan and Shogun
while also developing Mandalore's Moon
Concordia but during this time they were
undergoing a sort of religious
revolution over these thousands of years
of fighting it came about that the
Mandalore saw the old God CAD Harang
here as not a true and separate entity
that needed to be worshipped with
special rights developed for him this
was in a way a full of idolatry
worshipping a construct instead of the
act of war itself it wasn't this God but
the whole universe that was created and
developed by the act of dominating the
microscopic organism with a slight
advantage over its competitors devours
them to the forming of a connective a
process of absorbing your neighbouring
space debris proto itself larger the
black hole devours light itself and yet
still can be swallowed up by a larger
black hole yup the Powell interstellar
Korean is a law of the universe yup
therefore the rituals to can her rain
gear were a distraction from this
universe of presence
thus orders are will they cover a legend
like this that we can follow on earth so
they've realized that anyone white we
just started chatter was in tune with
this divine plan that combat was the one
and only true form abortion yes system
old God but you personally were carrying
out the Divine Will and thus in that
moment you yourself are divine not only
is this more real Isaac's way to rally
our satyrs but this Minds must be how
much bullying the first ever nan Tong
mandos with them in Dali oh wow where
those big ursula Mandalorian were your
culture so much that they adopted their
culture we're now in the year 4000 BBY
who liked fighting I like fighting than
the puta species but they did absorb
many as Colonia slaves but also
destroyed the Dragons these were highly
intelligent
like species in this conflict would be
the first time that men DeLoreans faced
off against Jedi the order sent over
some screw the Jedi combined force of
the Crusaders the basilisks poisoned
their own world to deny it to the
conquerors but some were taken as slaves
while their machines the basilisk wards
were captured and have become a staple
of the Crusader military from here they
launched an attack into the deep core
into the unstable and Pristina system
they conquered a few worlds which got
the attention of Jedi Knight turned
sethe warlord
Kulik held Roma Mandalore the endowment
oh right oh yeah his war troy'd and
bhaskar armor he was defeated in swore
allegiance to quell drama in his sethe
master Exar Kun this marked the first
Mandalorian said alliance this was
during an event called the first Seth
war also known as the great shadow
crusade - the Mandalorian people which
was fought in a single year 3900 be
damned if this new alliance launched a
daring raid on the Republic shipyards
over forests here they obtained as much
as 300 starships miss Litella they went
directly to the Republic's capital
attacking the home of the original
Mandalorians chorus important tactic
city but were betrayed by their allies
the craft which in the Mojito
she also abandoned a Celt romo to the
Jedi forces Mandalore the indomitable
was able to escape can stress descend on
ya before explaining the situation the
pair teamed up and personally raided the
Senate building in rescue drama which
was dispatched by the trio and they
decided to abandon Khorasan for now
later Lex brought the best liske war
toys up against the Beast riders and
drechsel's on onderon
as they attempted to take the capital
city of Isis on Durin's moon dachshund
has an order that places the two my
sister Star Wars his mount was shot down
and he plummeted into the thick jungle
of this moon here a swarm of beasts
devoured the indomitable swamis his
distinct helmet became a symbol of the
sole ruler without a Mandalore many of
the clans start to fracture
but the helmet was discovered by a Tom
when lived through that battle he
removed it and declared himself
Mandalore the ultimate he realized the
night had been dragged into the witch's
machinations and failed to restore the
Mandalorians to the great warrior status
they once held on the planet Shogun
which years earlier had shown the
indomitable that the old gods are false
now gave Mandalore the ultimate a vision
of the tongue species going extinct
this time the tongue species made up the
bulk of Mandalorians it was then that
kept hurling themselves at the Republic
and the Jedi but he knew that the
Mandalorian values were not bound to the
Tong species and so we formed neo
Crusaders he traveled the galaxy giving
rousing speeches to those willing to
embrace the martial principles humans
were the most populous and widespread
species in the galaxy and this is why
the majority of human DeLoreans were
human but there were also tons of
Rodin's Twi'leks Tagore ian's and
caressed IANS from this moment on her
Mandalorian really started to become
untied to the tongue species now it was
more about the culture about twenty
years after the previous war now three
thousand nine hundred and seventy-eight
BBY a pureblood Sith species contacted
mentor the ultimate and enticed him to
search Sith ruins for insight into the
future this synth was working for the
mysterious of Emperor and used his
powers in the force to instill visions
of Mandalorians conquering the Republic
inspired by promises of victory the neo
Crusaders started to capture neutral
territory it's visual line years they
controlled a larger area than all of the
Hutt clans intimate appointed a man
named Casas phat to be the top military
strategist and he promptly accelerated
the capture of more worlds one of the
pets contributions was the
standardization of armor something that
helped to create a more cohesive
identity across the diverse species and
ensured that the galaxy at large knew
when they were dealing with the
Mandalorian he also battled a dual
pronged economic assault in which these
captured neutral worlds deprived the
of imports while the Mandalorians took
the local population as slave labor and
focused all of these planet's resources
to the sole task of creating more
weapons and ships for the eventual war
with the Republic this caused an
importing of refugees that caused
internal strife and economic pressures
compounding the weakness of losing these
neutral world's senators said that the
Republic would only intervene if
directly attacked and all this time the
ultimate had set up training grounds
deep in the jungle of Jackson the place
where his predecessor had been devoured
these camps are one of the greatest
embodiments of their culture training
against the very creatures that had
felled their leader lifting up the rank
and file to a greater strength than the
best among them in just a generation
before in three thousand nine hundred
and sixty-four they sprang up from the
secret camp and took under on Banquo and
Taurus in a shocking let's create Jedi
named Revan and Malak became aware of
some of the Mandalorian dragons some of
which included a nuclear power arguments
of entire worlds these two Jedi refused
to stand by eventually leading Republic
forces in pushing the Mandalorians back
he came across the helmet of a
Mandalorian woman who opposed bets
Jennison upon downing it i sweared that
he would not rest into the Mandalorians
have been completely defeated and Star
Wars as well he works to pull most of
the Mandalorian forces to Mallik or five
here the Jedi leader had the drawn this
world's immense Darkseid energy in order
to defeat Mandalore the ultimate in a
duel
after this he activated the mass shadow
generator which destroyed most of the
Mandalorian please
Oh juice without their Emperor or a
proper Navy they signed a peace treaty
with the Republic worried about a rise
of the Mandalorians but revin said
simply without the mask
they are nothing a cold statement or he
is acknowledging that he is destroying
an entire culture simply by holding on
to this mask depriving them of a leader
will just lead to fracturing and
infighting that will eventually erase
the Mandalorian identity from history
Zack what happens to the Gregor Lords
Theory infrastructure incorporated along
this once proud people trying to keep up
their traditions
we're spread out across
galaxy and often resorted to taking up
odd jobs as hired gun and then people
became cause later became known as the
Mandalorian mercs with notable
individuals like gorse vendek achieving
gladiatorial Fame on Terrace and
Geonosis in Candra Sordo becoming one of
the most infamous marks in the galaxy
but as the force would have it he
crossed paths with revin who now
understood that the Mandalorians were
being manipulated into warring with a
hidden civ emperor revin gave the helmet
to order we have very proud people he
took the name Mandalore the preserver he
meant with what may have been the final
remaining tong in the galaxy this being
was dying but explained that he was the
rightful heir to Mandalore the
indomitable that the ultimate had used
to sit backing to take over a bag that
Ordo take his armor and Riaan still some
of the virtues from the canons of Honor
order would be the first read this he
went back to the roots growing a new
following of neo Crusaders on the
outpost of Jackson he's thought about
what was my hands to sit around for it
helped the Onderon royal family and even
provide aid to the Republic and or the
preserver personally aided the raid on
darth nihilus flagship even providing
the externally I had were used to blow
it into space now the next 300 years of
Mandalorian history is a bit foggy but
it is clear that clan or doe does not
fully use what kind of [ __ ]
documentary is this
so Imperial Intelligence Agency on each
of his victories this man seemed
invincible and many of the diaspora were
happy to call him their new leader the
sith revealed themselves as allies
where's my compound interest blockade
the hiding
cutting off a major republic supply line
as the Empire expanded in the outer rim
andalorian cruisers were too powerful
for a straight-up attack so the Republic
had to rely on blockade breaking
smugglers to rally up his supporters
this puppet Mandalore announced the
great hunt on Taksin to determine who
would become his best warrior winning
best friends and in line with the old
true virtues challenged Mandalore to a
duel and the gladiator pits on Geonosis
this propped up leader was slaughtered
an artist took the name Mandalore the
vindicated his predecessor is only known
in the history books as an insult
Mandalore of the lesser it was much more
cautious but knew that the early drags
allowed him to consolidate power but
again not all respected the centralized
leader in splinter groups like clan
Murad in the terror brigade had launched
attacks against both seviper and the
republic the vindicated would be
eliminated during the rise of the
eternal if indicated eliminated the
troopers death by Troy dishonorable this
whole conflict created a strong anti
droid sentiment that would stick in
Mandalorian culture from here on out
Komal Fett could have chosen the take on
the mantle but he didn't want the
responsibility so instead the infamous
bounty hunter shave Isla became
Mandalore the Avenger previously she had
been allied to Darth Malgus
assisted her in battles from Alderaan
even against the Jedi Temple now she
would join the lnder in the Alliance a
combination of Sith and Republic ho ho
what's that Bromley just a threat the
orgonite Rhodes posed to the galaxy I'm
an ancient eternal force was destroyed
it's her let's just peace for the next
thousand plus years that is until the
noose if Wars spanning from 2000 BBY
some purple lights say there's nothing
there's no lorian's fighting against
their once allies this is the Empire the
reasons behind this are still shrouded
in hell yeah but everything points to
this doesn't matter we're fighting the
baddies submitting a constant complaint
by Mandalorians of this era that there
once righteous holy Crusades of violence
in accordance with the laws of the
universe had been forgotten
is all just for treasure around this
time is where we also get Mandalorian
training master Chang raising agenda oh
my god I see that creature and less
attractive 20 but eventually in the fish
base in the Attic when he felt that they
were merely hired guns the pair were
taken in by a sniper notices who
enhanced their strength and longevity in
exchange for protection
they stole my life during a raid all
refills but dirt rag was able to
Massacre the attackers devoted his life
to killing Mandalorians Darth Bane would
bring an end to the Sith Empire yeah and
apparently in order to ensure galactic
peace as the Warlord's were still not
fully under the control of the Mandalore
the Republic invaded Mandalore itself in
fighting against rival clans allowed the
Republic a total victory with weapons
used by both the Republic and the
Mandalorians creating an enormous
Cataclysm an environmental disaster that
turned much of this rich world into the
barren white sand deserts that now cover
its surface this is where we get the new
Mandalorians a faction with very
contentious origins many believe that
they were propped up by the Republic to
coax them into abandoning their culture
the new Mandalorian said that the cans
of Honor only leads to death and ruin
that strength could only come by working
together by peacefully partaking in the
Republic system Wow very very Jedi were
said to be leading the assault in the
dark saber may have been stolen by the
Jedi Temple around 1000 BBY the lure and
the dark saber is not clear simply
stating that it was stolen during the
fall of the Old Republic it is said to
be around a millennium before the Clone
Wars which would have been when the
Republic was heavily involved in the
Sith Wars Tory vizla descendant of
Mandalore the Avenger of shave Islam was
the only Mandalorian to become a Jedi it
was able to temporarily one Mandalorian
he was doing
a sign of the sole ruler replacing the
role helmet that's my selection of
Mandalore is not a story the Republic
would tell you but they and the Jedi
definitely played a role
it wasn't solely the result of a civil
war amongst clans but whenever you think
of that it worked and these were now a
pacifist people I think avoiding
crushing sentence narrating there's a
domed cube cities and the leaders came
to take the names from other cultures
like King Queen and Duchess no longer
calling themselves the Mandalore those
unable to give up the warrior code were
sent to the moon Concordia and the site
of armor wearing Mandalorians became
incredibly rare on Mandalore these few
called themselves the Akali or faithful
and they did keep a leader that they
called mandala for with the last-named
one being a genocide will maniac named
Mandalore the destroyer he took over
after his predecessor was killed by
dirge still carrying out murderous raids
against mandos in the year 100 of you
are around 69 I hope this shows you're
the Battle of Naboo the Mandalorian
Civil War gun you can make us well it's
equals the super commando codex a sort
of revised chivalry which stated that it
is still noble and morally necessary to
learn the martial arts but that these
skills should not be used to conquer and
the old survival of the fittest
framework instead therefore protecting
the rights of individuals but Torv isla
hated this past year the new passes Oh
God gesture morale was the leader of
Tiryns mana lorrison never see it he and
his horses were pushed off of Mandalore
to the agricultural world of Concord
dawn the local police force in a
position called the journeyman protector
and one of them allowed the true
indo-aryan horses to hide out on his
property and so they set up camp at the
fat farm this la found out that this man
was hiding more real and brutally
interrogated him in front of the man's
son
mama Fett sprung up out of hiding and
unloaded her blaster rifle into Death
Watch
troops she was killed in the fighting
and his father ordered the son to run
into the fields this eight-year-old
Jango Fett picked up on a real who
raised the boy as his own teaching him
the new ways of the Mandalorians the
fighting between these carvings spanning
nearly two decades and it also saw a 14
year old Jango Fett hold his dying
adopted father in his arms and they've
started to score significant victories
in 44 BBY but vizla and Death Watch
turned to political corruption when they
couldn't win on the balance Shango Galit
ran the concocted a story of war crimes
committed by the true Mandalorian forces
the Jedi Order gets involved and
believed the claims that Betts forces
were killing political activists
including innocent women and children
Count Dooku led a strike team to capture
fat okie hoping to get to the bottom of
these claims but the Mandalore refused
to be brought in on false claims he knew
that if he was removed for trial Death
Watch would certainly regain their
strength so fat and the true mandos
opened fire
the shootout resulted in 11 dead Jedi
which were shot by Jango personally all
of his forces were cut down but was
indeed captured and turned over to the
corrupt Gallagher and company angle that
was a well they kill six Jets but you
don't get the reputation for being a
galactic badass on your looks alone
Jango was able to escape break into the
governor's office and steal back his
trophy armor and then track down and
kill vizla seeing that both the local
governments and even the Jedi Order
could be so easily manipulated by evil
and also being hardened by the war and
life as a slave Jango Fett dedicated his
life to being a bounty hunter and on his
armor he would proudly bear his adopted
father sigil colaborate did forgive the
Jedi Order but ironically who'd become
allied to the Jedi that led
that strike team that forever changed
his life the Mandalorian Civil War was
terrible for the individuals that
directly experienced it but it was a
relatively pretty good for everyone else
most the only affecting Mandalore itself
in a few of its neighboring worlds even
the amount of those involved is a great
minority of the population which helped
the pacifist movement even more now as
when duchess satine comes to power
pushing a pacifist agenda even further
about twenty years before the opening of
the Clone Wars in 32 BBY the
bounty-hunting Django was approached by
Darth Tyranus to create a clone army it
is unclear if this Fallen Jedi used the
promise of order 66 to entice Jango
whether or not he knew that his clones
be used to take down his enemies in the
Jedi Order ensure these away the Kamino
one's brought him in not just for
genetic donation but also for hands-on
training and even the designing of these
troops armor this is why clone troopers
have a similar tea visor appearance been
personally trained the first batch of
alpha class arc troopers instilling
Mandalorian traditions and even ensuring
that they Hemmer eyes the song go day on
meaning brothers all an ancient chant
sung and we gotta learn a language and
which mentions that they are the wrath
of Khorasan gives it a nice dual meaning
given how the clones were used by the
Republic and that Khorasan is the
original homeworld of the Tong species
then Jango established the coy avatar a
group of 100 sergeants seventy five of
which were Mandalorians members like
cows karana helped to infuse Mandalorian
culture even further though Palpatine
would take Harris's face out these
Mandalorian Leo DiCaprio with long
benches not receiving this rich cultural
tradition back on Mandalore Satine bound
to keep neutral during the Clone Wars
but Death Watch sought out Dooku as an
ally they attacked a republic cruiser
and spread rumors on Confederate worlds
that the new Mandalorians were actually
supporting the Republic this is why
obi-wan was dispatched to meet us a team
a woman that he came to love after being
assigned to protect her in the final
months of e1 talent well remember that
and adores Moon Concordia was the exile
place for all the old Mandalorians those
trying to keep up the war
big traditions it was governed by Pre
Vizsla who was secretly supporting the
production of previous jetpacks and pole
suits of armor all for the purposes of
overthrowing the pacifists this sparked
a really controversial move by the
Republic who after learning that Death
Watch now had such growth and backing
sent a large peacekeeping force any
Mandalorians opposed this seeing it as
occupation and proved that the Republic
still believe that the Mandalorians were
too dangerous and unpredictable to rule
themselves this brought more traders out
of the shadows like Senator Marek who
was thought to be one of the Duchess's
most trusted allies his scheme would
mark the start of several assassination
attempts while Dooku started giving more
and more support to Death Watch even
offering to provide Mandalorian people
with CIS droids to protect them from the
unwanted Republic clone issues then it
seemed like her deputy prime minister
jerec turned on her calling for more
Republic aid in claiming that this new
civil war was due to her weak leadership
but this was in fact a hollow vid deep
fake and though Jarek was assassinated
his true message was revealed saying
that competence could fight death watch
without Republic aid but there was a
partying nasty little move by the
Republic seen as a tumultuous world
Republic trade was banned from traveling
through Mandalorian space this worked to
grow a black market set up in part by
the Duchess's closest ally prime
minister almond a man who betrayed the
Duchess simply because he didn't want to
give up some of the imports that he
loved this decadence is a long way from
the Spartan living of the earlier
mandamus in this seat of corruption
swanky ministers even the new
Mandalorian Secret Service all Mike
attempted to have Satine framed but it
backfired and he ended up in prison by
20 BBY Death Watch had a falling out
with Dooku seeing that he was just
keeping up with the long tradition of
SIV that just used the Mandalorians and
don't actually care about the fate of
Mandalore lux bonteri hoped to use their
aid to help him avenge his mother a
piece wanting separatist leader that had
been killed by Dooku conscience impaired
met by Bogut on and Pre Vizsla but they
were unwilling to
by his death watch others for the plan
fell apart they do escape here Death
Watch hired a new ally who hated both
the Republic and the Sith let's see is
Darth Maul and yang a criminal empire
known as the shadow collective by
sending hordes of criminals to invade
the capital they were able to make Death
Watch appear like the heroes Pre Vizsla
publicly confronts a teen and has her
arrested Isla would be the new prime
minister of Mandalore but not for long
Darth Maul knew his Mandalorian culture
and at Bislett was gonna assure back the
old customs he could not be seen to turn
down a challenge to a duel the fighting
was intense
Amal would win the battle and proclaim
himself the new member
focus on and the night owls refused to
submit and so had to fight against Death
Watch just layers of civil wars here
she was actually Satine sister who would
come back to help obi-wan escape malls
capture but only after mall used a team
to deal one of the hardest losses that
Kenobi would ever experience coldly
killing the Duchess in front of him just
to make his oldest enemy suffer Oh
things were so out of control that
Sidious personally visits Mandalore he
cut down mom's brother then defeat small
and takes him prisoner it should be
pointed out that throughout this
incredibly volatile time you can see
that even the pacifists had Mandalorian
artwork that was embracing their past as
warriors with visions of the Crusaders
and even vanquish Jedi before he was
captured Maul had put Prime Minister
Olmec in as his puppet leader and he
would continue ruling while the sbrick
was in prison that's the GM Prime the
mall DeLoreans the super commando still
loyal to him freed Maul and they
returned to Mandalore due to the
encouraging of Bo Catan and obi wan's
personal testimony the Republic agreed
to siege Mandalore and take it out of
the hands of a known Sith trained to
crime warlord if they were worried about
the planet before it doesn't get much
worse than that ahsoka tano had left the
Jedi Order at this point but she
returned to lead a detachment of clone
troopers during the siege she confronts
Maul and gets in one of the best Barb's
in galactic history there's a snippet of
the conversation
maul says it was so nice of your former
masters to send you alone and spare me
the exertion of a proper flight you're
not even a real Jedi ahsoka says it'll
be a fair fight then you're only half as
it
haha Tana was able to draw them all into
a ratio trap but as this force is
conveyed she was left with the choice of
finishing him off or saving Rex he's cut
him he chose her a long time clone ally
and everyone survives but as the siege
carried on he was eventually driven off
Mandalore in bogota becomes the region
of Mandalore this was probably the best
shot in their history and a stable
government with a balance of good
military self-reliance embodied in a
peace craving ruler but alas it was
erase playbook during the Imperial era
she was deemed traitorous and replaced
with Clan Saxon was willing to do the
Emperor's bidding but there were some
other holdovers Ben Rao of the
protectors opposed Death Watch and his
gold squadron
aided the GA are in various operations
throughout the Clone Wars once rally
even helped to save the life of a young
Kanan jars after the war competeing
allowed the protectors to consolidate
power and Mandalore space with their
main base being on a moon of Concord
dawn Clan Saxon converted itself into
Imperial super commandos and in the year
to BBY they wiped out the protectors
this ensured that his clan was the sole
ruler of Mandalore and that Palpatine's
favored when it switched to rau one day
also that year the spectres discovered
that Maul had been hiding the dark saber
on earth aamir they recovered it and
encouraged Sabine Wren to start training
with it now I need the immense
responsibility connected to this weapon
she was reluctant but the now rebel
aligned fan trail supported her she
returned to her clan stronghold and
tried to get her mother to join the
rebellion but Saxon
there were ups an epic Mandalorian
showdown it would make her ancestors
proud with the dark saber in the hands
of this sellout Mandalore completely
Sheriff lightsaber she does one the day
and Saxon dies but this of course now
drag Mandalore into another civil war
within Pyarelal I demand OHS versus
those sentinel joining the rebellion
remaining independent drawn at this time
and knows and when Ezra is able to
escape he got some of Sabine's allies to
provide help this cannot be overstated
but the rebellion may have died this day
if it wasn't for the mando strike team
destroying the interdictor I was
preventing rebel ships from jumping the
hyperspace
it's about this opening Iran would have
certainly killed all that remains sabine
been tried to offer the dark saber to
Bogota but she turned it down this pair
along with other allied clans try to
push the Empire off Mandalore but the
Duchess was unveiled this prototype
weapon was created by Sabine and years
before when she was serving as an
imperial weapon designer this insidious
weapon draws dark energy to the best bar
alloy in the Mandalorian armor allowing
it to be used on the battlefield without
hurting the stormtroopers in their class
toy doctor
knowing how inextricably tied armor is
to Mandalorian culture and how the
discovery of best scar was a sign that
Mandalore was the promised land a
material that was hoped to have kept
them out of the timeless battles between
the lightsaber wielding Sith and Jedi
was now named after the Duchess and used
to vaporize Mandalorians on this
promised land luckily they were able to
destroy this weapon and seeing that her
people were in serious need of a sole
ruler Oh Katan accepted the dark saber
became the new Mandalore all this time
Django's unaltered clone boba fett was
rising to take on his father's mantle
becoming the top bounty hunter
but instead of coming back to fight for
Mandalorian independence he served the
empire as a hired gun
after the fall of the Empire there was
another badass who was known simply as
the Mandalorian his background and
values are still unknown but he is just
another sign of the undying Mandalorian
culture with things like the sigil of
the mythos or being seen in places like
maz kanata's castle
and perhaps even the Mandalorian himself
helping to finish the fight against the
Emperor the final sip Emperor the last
in a long line of Sith that have plagued
the Mandalorians for millennia so that
concludes the story of the Mandalorians
in a separate video I'll cover behind
the scenes facts because those are deep
and interesting on their own there's not
long enough thermic also cover weapons
ships tank and society in more detail
later guys make sure to subscribe to
this new video social media find ways
that you can help support this channel
without it costing you a thing or check
out our patreon be sure to check out the
links in the description special shout
out to our supporters over on patreon
but most important of all remember only
two things are responsible for all the
events in Star Wars history the force
and the man Kathleen Kennedy and so the
force and the Mandalorians will be with
you always
not one mention of George Lucas this
entire video yeah man it's bigger than
the man himself now clear clearly yeah
one man created one movie and we spawned
all this this is history for history it
isn't even existed there are 300 missing
years for this fake history which is
like amazing in a way it's like Lord of
the Rings you know I guess what makes it
especially surprising to me is like if
you're gonna compare to Lord of the
Rings era token he made these books
which I feel like it's easier to enhance
the mythos to it and he died a while ago
George Lucas did this like 50 years ago
well and now we got this like crazy
universe in world
and I'm bringing him up because I know
you didn't like direct Empire Strikes
Back I don't even think he wrote that
one I'm pretty sure it was like he was
heavily involved in the story creation
this is one guy Boba Fett who just look
cool yeah do at least a half hours worth
of completely involved thousands of
years where the visitor I mean beyond
that it's like what he did here I mean
thank you so much for putting this
together
meta nerds lore make sure to subscribe
this guy as soon as you can like this
took a lot of work of what you had to
assemble from today I'll only have like
rebels and Clone Wars footage to go from
little bits of movies examples and the
books and everything cept art there's so
much you had to pull from in order to
absorb this yeah I mean we've been
watching the show the Mandalorian and
then who Italy to watch a show called
the Mandalorian and to be five episodes
and I'm like you should have called it a
Mandalore specific kind of man because
he attitudes and practices but but I
think he isn't interesting at least in
that themes that the show has been
hinting at a midpoint between the
inclinations of the Mandalorian people
you know from looking at the Mandalorian
show and then with all the information
provided here he's kind of this like
transitional sort of character Jannik
neutral meeting a different point yeah
for a good Mandalore's you know you're
hearing all this history of starting off
like from the very beginning they
weren't even humans at first yeah
they're all just about combat we just
love fighting and fighting is the way to
life now that is the endgame here though
cuz if you wipe out everybody and this
just you guys do you have to wipe
yourselves out in order to reach the
divine yeah generously socialized we
know what are you fighting just pick a
fight all the time yeah did you how do
you maintain the community I lost count
of how many civil wars there happened
and then there were also it seemed like
there would be different cultures and
races and species it'd be like I liked
your culture we're gonna adopt it but
you're not us so we're fighting because
we like madolora culture because nobody
like battle or fight
the thing is those people come in and
they're like oh this is perfect welcome
welcome wait a minute you don't match
our ideals let's get some conflict and
that's why like I'm looking at the show
now which is so much about a
cold-hearted Mandalorian another one
like Jango Fett who was adopted into the
Mandalore culture watching him really
develop a heart hmm and these human
values these core values of care you
know with baby Yoda you know that is
really fascinating and enriching and I
imagine that journey would probably be a
lot more rewarding if I was aware of
half of this cuz how big a deal it is I
mean like the show does a good job at
making you go okay I'm assuming the
Mandalorian culture has a lot to do with
being a badass yeah and when weapons are
a part of your religion you can only
assume being a warrior I was under the
impression that most of them were bounty
hunters I thought it was like a bounty
hunter culture yeah
so I thought this whole thing with
Mandalorians became this over a
glorified thing from omitting to
misperceptions is what I'm doing now I'm
not saying this is what it is
but I was like with Boba Fett I was like
all right he looked cool he was alright
in the Christmas special whatever
animated thing apparently and then he
had a cheap death in Return of the Jedi
let's make a whole lore out of bounty
hunters and then come to find out oh
there's this like whole crazy sounds a
year's involved in the history way
before the prequels even came out and
I'm like who came up with oh yeah it's
who came up with all this well that's
the thing that's funny is is it's
interesting I mean going back to that
Tolkien Lucas comparison ostensibly for
token a lot of that was just like coming
up with it on his own you know he's a
linguistics expert a history expert and
like you know George Lucas had to have
had some of that in here too but yeah
this is like the complete opposite where
it's like you have this lore that has
been expanded by a whole community of
different creative minds now even fans
are affecting it in ways or fans who get
to grow up and become the people who get
to add to the Canon it's like a katamari
of creativity and it does fasten it like
it's weird it's so fascinating to me
that you can have such an involved
history that when you listen to it
sounds like an actual history it like
this reminded me watching like the
history of the entire world video but
for a history that doesn't actually
exist yeah that's kind of beautiful
about the whole thing is cuz it's more
than just going over plot points like
they got these mantras literal like
texts these books like chronicles of oh
my god this is nuts oh how come earth
has never involved you know we're the
weenie planet of the universe we haven't
figure we got cars that's what we
figured
Star Wars seems like this awesome
fantastical traveling the galaxy thing
and then when you hear about what it's
always going on why it's called Star
Wars a low-res it seems like it's much
better on earth dude
episode I just care about making my bill
there's gonna be a major twist we're a
long long time ago in a galaxy far far
away is actually in present-day ER yeah
finn and rey and everybody Poe they'll
land on earth what is this place
none of our stuff works every Star Wars
movie post-credit scene after whatever
big giant space battle they have or one
on one lightsaber fight they have every
post-credit scene should be meanwhile on
earth
oh honey this light bulbs not working no
I'm really I'm just I'm really conflict
averse okay I just I just don't want to
deal with any of these who should I say
something no I don't I don't think I
would have been as interested or as like
strongly focused on this video if I
wasn't so into the Mandalorian show but
what I found funny about the experience
in this documentary that he put together
is the Mandalorian show seems to be
solely about this one character a very
unique kind of Mandalore character now
it's making me wonder because they show
that there's other Mandalorians that he
can keep in contact with where he gets
to steal from his armor so
whatsapp together so are we gonna
explore these other kinds of
Mandalorians you know cuz there's
clearly a whole bunch of other people
there's other species that rock this
armor there's Mandalorian culture within
Mandalorian culture there's a whole
variety of it yeah so while we've been
exploring this one character in the show
it would be cool if they really do start
diving more into the history and the
culture man you have to give me this so
like big dump like the way it doesn't
have to be a serial this yeah exactly
but explore different kinds of
characters at work there's a clash of
cultural beliefs within the Mandalorians
I think would be really neat to go into
yeah showing it in a character or
itching way I knew I mean you get a
taste of that in that third episode
there but I hope that they use that as
an opportunity to come back later and do
some more of that because this video has
shown anything it's that the Mandalorian
people have gone through such a
evolution over time and over so many
phases of the galaxy and of the universe
yeah well like you could I mean if the
show the shows doing well so I yeah
would really love to see them expand
upon this this show does these things to
make our character confront the confines
of his culture so it seems like it's
there you know yeah so hopefully as also
it's just awe-inspiring how much there
is to draw from well I mean in the epic
I'm assuming everyone who's what
happened to watch this reaction with us
and this year has seen the show what's
the UM so but in Episode three when
the Mandalorians all band together to
help out our main hero I feel like
that's especially more rewarding now
that I've seen this yes so much of it
was like I don't agree you know but you
know there was a bigger conflict there
just like no idea what the small
conflict we can fight a whole time
oh we love funny he started good on you
yeah rocks off first they're like this
guy's not very Mandalorian all right now
he a dumb game we love fighting the head
they thought I hey guys in a big fight a
big fight I guess one thing that I would
keep tying it back to the show this this
is making me think about where the show
could go with the Mandalore character
that we have he's very much a bounty
hunter and with this I want to see more
of the warrior come out because I've
been so into the bounty hunter stuff and
it's it is a Western bounty hunter or
space show but now I'm like no let's see
some of that warrior [ __ ] come out now
oh you know I don't really five episodes
in there's more to go but yeah that's
what I want anyway guys I'm gonna say it
again
subscribe to meta nerds lore this
channel is so much more I want to check
out now who's are the three most popular
things in culture mister D and lore got
it all down make sure to subscribe to
this channel as soon as you can thank
you for putting this video together you
can subscribe with the real rejects
click on notification or I'll get
notified never got a video up hit that
like button if you liked that video and
now check out our Mandalorian reactions
as soon as you can TJ he changed my man
TJ trakis thank you so much dude I know
even wanting us to get more into some
more Star Wars content as of late looks
like it's begun so recently I asked TJ
since you've been watching the
Mandalorian what has been your favorite
episode so far and he said so far I'd
have to say the second the ending with
all the Mandalorians joining the fight
was just too good I've been loving all
of it though
fake nerd ik nerd that was the third
episode Wow you idiot Wow gosh
GJ how stupid can you be
did somebody recommend this video to you
to recommend to us is that what happened
here all this time or you just gotta be
video chatting you with the past no
source books at the back you can't even
remember that you're one episode off
here I think you can't even read away
his next message was oh I meant the
third episode the first to kind of blend
it cuz it's on the same planet still you
messy on the first time what gives so I
won't forgive you but if we were
Mandalorians this would be friggin rad
though cuz we got a conflict now gotta
go fight kick his ass
thanks T Jimmy you know we just messin
with you how do your daughter